Україна ніколи не перекривала вентиль. Це важливо зрозуміти.
У нас немає такої традиції: виходити на телеекран
і говорити: ми перекриваємо вентиль. Нема в нас такого.
У Росії є люди, які кажуть, що "Україна краде газ з труби".
Україна ніколи не крала газ. Читаєш - і голос Левітана чути в вухах.
Яку роль у розв'язанні суперечки між Росією й Україною
відіграє Берлін?
Німеччина повинна розуміти, що таким чином
вона фактично сприяє економічному задушенню України.
Це ринковий інструмент чи шантаж?
"Газпром" повинен буде заплатити нам
загалом 11,8 мільярда доларів
в межах цих позовних вимог.
Юрію Юрійовичу, Ви написали у Фейсбук,
що якщо до кінця року не буде підписано
новий договір про транзит газу між Україною і Росією,
з січня Україна почне закачувати у підземні газосховища
російський газ нібито як "безгоспний".
Це офіційна позиція "Нафтогазу України"
й українського уряду, правильно я розумію?
Це офіційна позиція українського законодавства.
Тобто якщо газ буде надходити на територію України
без документального оформлення,
то, з одного боку, ми не можемо і не будемо перекривати вентилі,
припиняючи потік газу, але при цьому
українське законодавство не буде дозволяти оператору
газотранспортної системи випускати цей газ
куди-небудь без документального оформлення.
Тому його закачуватимуть до підземних газосховищ
як газ "невизначеного власника",
а ми будемо чекати документального оформлення,
і тільки після цього оператор зможе направити цей газ
туди, куди власник з відповідними документами скаже цей газ направити.
У Росії є люди, які кажуть, що "Україна краде газ з труби".
Те, що Ви пропонуєте закачувати російський газ
у підземні сховища як "безгоспний", -
це приклад такої крадіжки?
Навпаки, ми якраз показуємо, що, по-перше, Україна ніколи не крала газ.
Ми говоримо про те, що якщо надходитиме газ
без документального оформлення,
тобто незрозуміло, чий це газ, то відповідно Україна
замість того, щоб якось спожити чи віддати комусь цей газ,
буде його надійно зберігати. Цілковито і весь.
Не буде його красти, не буде його забирати,
не буде його споживати, нічого з ним робити не буде,
а буде його зберігати доти, доки власник не прийде з документами.
Якщо ви загубили, умовно кажучи, багаж,
є спеціальний відділ, який називається lost and found,
який знайде ваш багаж і вам відповідно його віддасть.
Ось схожа ситуація й тут: є сховище газу,
газ буде зберігатися надійно доти, доки не буде
документального оформлення цих обсягів газу.
Скільки днів, тижнів або місяців ви можете
закачувати газ, який буде надходити без документів
на територію України як нічийний?
Є, звісно, фізичні обмеження. Ідеться про те, що
якщо буде якась затримка з підписанням контракту
і при цьому російська сторона буде продовжувати
закачувати газ на територію України, тоді таке
гіпотетично може статися.
Але я нагадаю, що в листі, який надіслав "Газпром" "Нафтогазу",
чорним по білому написано, що 1 січня о 10-й годині
за московським часом у "Газпрому" не буде підстав
для того, щоб газ надходив в Україну.
Тож ідеться не про те, що ми будемо робити з цим газом,
а про те, що "Газпром" дуже чітко заявив,
що фактично перекриє вентиль.
І з огляду на ті деталі, які згадані в листі -
10 ранку за московським часом - це читається як
залякування чи якась повістка. По суті, читаєш це -
і голос Левітана стоїть у вухах.
А те, що Ви пропонуєте закачувати газ
у підземні сховища в Україні - це не залякування?
Ні, навпаки, ми всіх заспокоюємо й говоримо:
не переживайте, нічого з вашим газом не відбудеться.
Якщо він буде надходити, він чекатиме свого господаря,
терпляче, коли господар прийде з оформленими документами.
І скільки газу можуть вмістити підземні сховища України?
Приблизно вся потужність українських сховищ -
від 25 до 30 мільярдів кубів.
Наразі вони заповнені до 21 мільярда кубів,
плюс зараз ми споживаємо з газосховищ, тобто взимку буде менше.
Але все це - гіпотетична дискусія.
По-перше, ми не хотіли нікого лякати. Більше того,
ми - на відміну від "Газпрому" -
написали про це не в листі, а на Фейсбук,
де я відповів одному з журналістів про те,
що станеться, якщо буде надходити газ без контракту.
Щоб усіх заспокоїти, що Україна не перекриватиме вентиль,
Україна ніколи не перекривала вентиль.
Це важливо зрозуміти. У нас немає такої традиції -
виходити на телеекран і говорити: ми перекриваємо вентиль.
Немає в нас такого. Ми просто говоримо:
не переживайте. Навіть у такій ситуації газ буде
терпляче чекати свого господаря.
Як ви ставитеся до того, що Німеччина
з запуском "Північного потоку-2" наступного року
де-факто забере в України роль
головного транзитера російського газу з Росії в Європу?
Дуже насторожено, тому що насправді йдеться
навіть не про те, що забере роль
головного транзитера, а про те, що транзиту
через територію України взагалі не буде.
Із запуском "Північного потоку-2" можна очікувати,
що транзиту через територію України взагалі не буде.
Німеччина повинна розуміти, що вона таким чином
сприяє економічному придушенню України.
Доходи від транзиту є дуже суттєвими
для української економіки, а весь український
і східноєвропейський газовий ринок
був сформований із розрахунку на те, що
газ ітиме зі Сходу на Захід. А такі радикальні зміни -
тепер газ ітиме із Заходу на Схід -
це загроза стабільності поставок у регіоні,
й Німеччина як один із лідерів ЄС повинна це усвідомлювати.
Наскільки я розумію, Ви вимагаєте від "Газпрому"
компенсацію в разі повного припинення
транзиту через українську територію?
Так, у рамках нового арбітражу,
який почав "Газпром", ми недавно змушені були
подати зустрічні позови. Вони включають
компенсацію за перегляд тарифу, який ґрунтується
на тому, що якщо не буде транзиту з 2020-го року,
нам доведеться нараховувати так звану прискорену амортизацію,
враховувати витрати на знецінення української ГТС
і ці витрати на прискорену амортизацію
включатимуться до відповідного тарифу.
І тому при перегляді тарифу "Газпром" повинен буде
заплатити нам загалом 11,8 мільярдів доларів
у рамках цих вимог у позові про компенсації щодо перегляду тарифу.
Ваші позови до "Газпрому" з вимогами компенсацій
у разі припинення транзиту газу з Росії в Європу
через територію України з нового року -
це ринковий інструмент чи шантаж?
Абсолютно ринковий механізм, який заснований
на тому, що в рамках нашого контракту чорним по білому написано:
є посилання на європейські правила, які, власне,
обумовлюють такий підхід до розрахунку тарифу.
Ми просто дотримуємося європейських правил,
які є в контракті. Важливо зрозуміти, що
європейські правила справедливі,
вони формувалися протягом десятиліть,
ці правила приймає російська сторона,
тому немає жодних підстав вважати, що
європейські правила дискримінаційні
по відношенню до Росії або несправедливі.
Ми не намагаємося тягнути на себе ковдру.
Ми говоримо про те, що європейські правила
багато в чому обмежують нас. Ми не можемо
отримати за транзит більше, ніж покриття наших витрат.
Ми навіть наші витрати обрізаємо, тому що
європейські правила не дають нам можливості
отримати компенсацію всіх наших витрат.
Ту частину наших витрат, які європейські правила
дозволяють нам покрити, ми збираємося покрити
через ці зустрічні вимоги у позові.
Конкретно хто й кому повинен зателефонувати,
щоб вирішити цю проблему?
Ми часто говоримо, що потяг уже пішов зі станції,
щоб можна було зателефонувати і вирішити питання.
Ми знаходимося в абсолютно іншому правовому полі.
Європейські правила, які були запроваджені
в Україні, не дозволяють телефонувати і вирішувати якісь питання.
Телефонне право лишилося в Радянському Союзі.
Є чітка законодавча база, європейські правила,
відокремлені оператори, незалежний регулятор,
комерційні компанії, в операційну діяльність яких
політики не можуть втручатися.
Є вже прийняті рішення судів, про які не можна просто так забути.
Тобто будь-яка людина, яка про них забуде,
при зміні влади або навіть при цій владі
попрямує до в'язниці, тому що це
пряме завдання збитків своїй компанії і своїй країні.
Тому ми просто пояснюємо всім: давайте жити
в цьому правовому полі, яке захищає всіх учасників процесу,
замість того, щоб хтось комусь подзвонив,
вирішив питання, а потім 11 років,
як у випадку з цими контрактами,
всі сторони мали негативні наслідки.
Але це ж політичне питання, і можна досягти
принципової домовленості на вищому політичному рівні?
Ми б хотіли це питання деполітизувати,
щоб замість політичного процесу
спокійно вирішувати комерційні, операційні,
юридичні питання в інтересах усіх сторін -
української, російської, європейської.
Як Ви гадаєте, це газ став заручником політики
чи політика стала заручницею газу?
Газ став заручником політики, на жаль.
Ми розуміємо, що рішення обійти Україну
з будівництвом "Північного потоку-2" і "Турецького потоку"
- це політичне, а не економічне рішення. На жаль,
весь сектор газу, навіть ті ж "Нафтогаз" і "Газпром",
страждають від того, що це питання надто політизоване.
Ключ до вирішення проблеми транзиту газу
лежить де? В якому місті?
У Берліні, Вашингтоні чи все ж таки у Москві?
Рішення знаходиться у Стокгольмі, де проходили
відповідні арбітражні слухання і де
міжнародний арбітражний трибунал
включно з представниками "Газпрому"
за процедурою, передбаченою в угоді, підписаній "Газпромом",
вирішував спірні питання. Є механізм вирішення
всіх спірних питань. Це Стокгольмський арбітраж.
Він уже вирішив низку питань, вирішує нові питання.
Ось ці питання, як їх вирішив Стокгольмський арбітраж,
рішення суду мають виконуватися,
а нові договори мають укладатися в відповідності
з європейськими правилами, які б включали
той самий припис, що Стокгольмський арбітраж
вирішує всі спірні питання.